these players all have one thing in
common
this Logan even though he plays on a
team in Germany and they play for a team
in Russia it's also on this team in
Serbia at games in England and on
sidelines in Italy the logo belongs to
Gazprom a Russian natural gas company
logo sponsorships are normal in soccer
teams make money offering jersey space
to sponsors selling things like credit
cards cars and cell phones but Gazprom
isn't like most sponsors private
companies with products soccer fans can
buy instead it's a company owned by the
Russian government that makes money
selling natural gas to foreign countries
yet it's everywhere in European soccer
so if soccer fans can't buy what they're
selling why's Gazprom spending millions
to sponsor soccer games
the answer is part of a larger story
that's changing the sport of soccer
foreign countries using companies they
own to burnish their reputations abroad
and to understand why Russia is involved
you need to look at a map Russia has the
world's largest natural gas reserves and
most of them are located in Arctic gas
fields controlled by Gazprom the company
is led by alexei miller a close ally of
vladimir putin since 2005 the Russian
government has owned a majority stake in
gas problem meaning company profits are
under Putin's control and gas sales
along with oil account for around 40
percent of Russia's annual budget this
map shows how dependent various European
countries are on Russian gas and you can
see that Eastern European countries are
more dependent than countries further
west at the end of the 20th century
Germany represented the biggest
opportunity for Gazprom German
Chancellor Gerhard schröder had
announced plans to phase out coal and
nuclear power which meant Germany would
need more natural gas to maintain their
energy supply
Gazprom wanted to get it to them
but there was a problem to get to
Germany Russia's gas needed to pass
through pipelines crossing countries
charging Gazprom transport fees and most
of them went through Ukraine a country
that has a complicated relationship with
Russia
today Ukraine still charges Russia two
to three billion dollars every year to
pump gas through to Europe so starting
back in 2005 Russia began working on a
strategy to bypass see grain and ship
their gas directly to Western Europe
this is the Nord Stream pipeline a route
through the Baltic Sea straight to
northern Germany in late 2005 Gazprom
was in the final stages of financing the
project and Germany's Chancellor was
preparing for an election during his
time in office Gerhard schröder had
become friendly with Putin and critics
in Germany were increasingly concerned
about the Russian leaders growing
influence just a few weeks before the
election Schroder met with Putin to sign
an agreement officially approving the
pipeline
two months later Schroder lost his
reelection but by March he had found a
new job overseeing gas promised pipeline
to Germany but each event alone can get
back Sonia will his baton this bargain
it also came out that before leaving
office Schroeder had approved a secret
Gazprom loan that provided over a
billion euros to finance the project
soon the story of Gazprom's big project
in Germany was becoming a story of
scandal corruption and the creeping
influence of Russia but then the story
changed in 2006 Gazprom signed a deal to
sponsor the German soccer team FC
schalke oh for at the time shell cos
finances were worrying team officials
and Gazprom sponsorship provided money
the team desperately needed at a press
conference announcing the deal a Gazprom
chairman said shell cos connections with
the German energy sector or why they
decided to become their sponsor Schalke
plays in Gelsenkirchen a town in
Germany's River Valley where much of the
country's energy industry is based it's
also close to the town of Raiden a hub
for pipelines to the rest of Europe and
home to Western Europe's largest natural
gas storage facilities
shelcha wasn't Gazprom's for soccer deal
the year before they had bought a
controlling stake in a team on the other
end of the Nordstrom route the Russian
team Zenit Saint Petersburg Gazprom's
investment made Zenit a major force in
soccer two years after taking control
Zenit won their first ever League
championship they've been able to sign
expensive foreign stars like Belgian
midfielder axel Witsel
and the Brazilian forward hull and
Gazprom uses Zenit for marketing stunts
like having players scrimmage on the
side of their offshore gas platform in
2006 as Gazprom logos were revealed
around Schalke stadium German headlines
were hailing the Russian gas giant for
pumping millions into the German team to
celebrate the deal shell cos new jersey
was unveiled in a ceremony before
Schalke and Zenit played a friendly
match in Russia and over the next few
years the Gazprom logo would become a
team symbol displayed at Schalke Games
and printed on official merchandise
Schalke also won a championship in 2011
and by then Nordstrom had been completed
in that year Gerhard schröder Angela
Merkel and other European officials
gathered to celebrate as it began
pumping gas to Germany there was also
another struggling team whose Jersey
started featuring gas problems logo the
Serbian Team Red Star Belgrade red star
was about 25 million dollars in debt
when gas proms signed to become their
jersey sponsor and again there was also
another pipeline the South Stream would
have bypassed Ukraine by going directly
through Serbia to southern Europe that
project closed in 2014 but Gazprom has
continued increasing their access to
Europe by building Nordstrom to
a second pipeline doubling the amount of
gas flowing from Russia to Germany
Gazprom has also expanded their soccer
empire to include energy partnerships
with Chelsea Football Club Champions
League and the sports most famous
tournament the FIFA World Cup these
sponsorships have made Gazprom's logo
familiar not just to fans in Europe but
across the world it's in commercials
before games and on jerseys and
sidelines once it starts FC schalke fans
have also started to see Nordstrom - ads
at home games and while climate
activists like Greenpeace have staged
protests to point out Gazprom's threat
to Arctic resources Gazprom has had no
trouble renewing their sponsorships now
Russia controls nearly half the gas
consumed by Europe and other countries
are learning from their example
Ettie odd Emirates and Qatar Airways are
all owned by sovereign states in the
Middle East with interests that go
beyond selling airline tickets as the
example of Gazprom shows having a
prominent soccer sponsorship offers away
around bad publicity by winning approval
on the field
if you're a fan that can feel like a big
opportunity their money helps teams win
major tournaments but it's starting to
change the sport itself now that it's
become common to see a Serbian team
sponsored by Russia's gas company facing
off against a French team sponsored by
Dubai state-owned airline it's starting
to seem like the field is hosting two
competitions at once a match between two
teams and a larger play for foreign
influence that continues long after the
final whistle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you